الجدل ام انه الجدل بيتقصدها الفنانه
شيرين خلال الفتره الماضيه ما بتخرج من
دائره الجدل ابدا فمن بعد مسلسل زواجها
والطلاق والعوده وازمه مرضها وكل ما تبعد
ذلك ومن بعد حفل دبي واللي صار فيه اخر
حلقات جدل شيرين ظهورها من ايام في برنامج
كاربولكاريوكي بالعربي مع هشام الهويش على
قناه دبي وهجومها اللي بصراحه ممكن نوصفوا
بغير المبرر ضد بعض زميلاتها البدايه كانت
في سؤال هشام للشرير اذا هي الوحيده اللي
بتستحق لقب صوت مصر وشيرين ردت عليه نعم
نعم ونص
اهلا بصوت مصري يا مرحبا بك
هل انت الوحيده التي تستحق هذا اللقب
جاوبيني بنعم او لا نعم الله اكبر الله
اكبر ما اقدرش
يا سلام على الثقه بالنفس ميه ميه
الاجابه اشعلت غضب جمهور النجمه الكبيره
انغام وللقب صوت مصر مرتبط فيها من زمان
واطلق عليها كثيرا في حفلات ولقاءات
وتصريحات وزاد اكثر ارتباط اللقب فيها من
بعد حفل ليله صوت مصر في الرياض من اسابيع
واللي تكرمت فيها النجمه عن مجمل مسيرتها
وغنت لاكثر من 5 ساعات في حفل مبهر يعني
صراحه انا حضرت الحفل وفعلا كان حفل روعه
يعني كان فعلا رائع طيب خلينا نرجع لتصريح
شيرين فجمهور انغام استغرب من تصريح شيرين
خاصه نبره التحدي اللي فيه وتحديدا ان نعم
ونص ودخلوا تويتر عبروا عن ارائهم وكسروا
الدنيا بهاشتاق انغام صوت مصر
الفنانه انغام كعادتها في مواقف من هذا
النوع ما ردت لكنها اكتفت على تويتر
بمجموعه من الريتويت لتغريدات مثل اللي
شفتوها لمغردين ومحبين بيعلقوا على
الموضوع وبيسموها صوت مصر الاول
والاخير الهجوم الثاني اللي اطلقته شيرين
في نفس اللقاء كان ضد اليسا اللي قالت
انها بتحب وضوحها لكن ما بتحب فيها انها
على المسرح بتغني وكانها ماسكه على
الجمهور شيكات
بحب
وضحا هي واضحه قوي في الوش
وما بحبش ساعات ان انا ان هي لما بتغني
بحس ان هي ماسكه على الناس شيكات
واخده عليهم الشيكات ههه بس هي واضحه
وجميله وقلبها حلو
يعني بتغني وهي محمل الجمهور جميله يعني
او مسويه فيهم كده معروف يعني اليسا ردت
على شيرين ونشرت التغريده اللي شايفينها
واللي فيها صورتين واحده لها على المسرح
ومكتوب فوقها ايش الجمهور بيشوف وانا
واقفه على المسرح وهنا اليسا بتتكلم عن
نفسها طبعا والصوره اللي جنبها لوحدها
ماسكه شيك ومكتوب فوقها هذا اللي شيرين
بتشوفه لكن اليسا حرصت في تغريدتها انها
تكتب
وهو تعبير انجليزي ممكن نترجمه انه يعني
من غير زعل او ماني شايله في قلبي شاي
وحطت كمان ايموجي وهي بتضحك
[موسيقى]